[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance FBI and congressional
investigators are reportedly scouring
evidence that Donald Trump may have met
privately 13 months ago with the Russian
ambassador who was at the Nexus of all
of the Trump Russia scandals this was
reported last week by NBC News and CNN
but it fell between the cracks that were
the cough a tweet and the abandonment of
the Paris climate Accord and it got no
traction and it is kind of important it
is in fact weapons-grade important in
short it's when Donnie met Sergey the
date was April 27 2016 the low-cal the
Mayflower Hotel in Washington the
sponsor the so-called center for the
national interest which is run by the
Russian emigre Dmitry Symes who has long
maintained a personal connection to the
Kremlin and Vladimir Putin along with
neocon Richard birch who among other
things is an advisor to the infamous
Russian outfit alpha bank this was not
some casual event the mayflower speech
was the first major foreign policy
address of Donald Trump's presidential
campaign and in the front row for it you
can see him in the pictures and the
video is the Russian ambassador Sergei
kiss react also in attendance
Jared clicker and Jeff Sessions is also
no secret that before the speech there
was a VIP reception at which quoting The
Wall Street Journal Trump warmly greeted
mr. kiss react and three other foreign
ambassadors who came to the reception
but just how warmly five current and
former US officials said they are aware
of classified intelligence suggesting
there was some sort of private encounter
between Trump and his aides and the
Russian envoy NBC reported despite a
heated denial from sessions we all know
how much credibility a heated denial
from sessions about meetings with
Russians should be given it is also
unclear at that VIP session and a
so-called private encounter between
Trump and kiss we are the same thing or
separate meetings but if you read a
little between the lines you get a sense
that there is some evidence somewhere
maybe from our intelligence people
surveilling kiss lyac or another
country's spies surveilling somebody
else that at some point on April 27th
2016 there were more words between Trump
and his entourage and kiss lyac
just the pleasantries of a receiving
line as described this past March by a
spokesman for that pro-kremlin group
that hosted Trump's speech moreover
those would seem to be words that are
just now ringing bells NBC quotes an
official who says the FBI is interested
in who was at the event and what was
said in the context of the
counterintelligence investigation into
Russian election meddling timing is as
always everything April 27th 2016 is
around the time that the Democratic
National Committee would begin to
realize there was unusual activity on
its computer network this would soon be
confirmed as the Russian hacking all the
NBC sources emphasized they only know
there is classified Intel about the
Trump kiss lack meeting or meetings they
don't know what it confirms or that it
confirms anything they and everybody
else know that this week Trump is up to
his neck in former FBI directors what
with James Comey scheduled to testify to
the Senate Intelligence Committee
Thursday at his predecessor the new
Justice Department Special Counsel
Robert Muller reportedly taking over
what had been a separate criminal
investigation into Paul Manafort and
Russia and also reportedly considering
expanding still further into
investigating the roles of Attorney
General Sessions and Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein in Trump's firing
of Comey and The Associated Press's
source on whether or not Muller legally
can investigate sessions and Rosen Stein
is a pretty good one it's Rosen Stein
himself as you will recall Trump has
reportedly at least mold invoking
executive privilege to keep Comey from
testifying but my friend John Dean and
others have pointed out that Comey is
now a private citizen and anyway the
subject of what Trump and Comey talked
about was discussed by Trump publicly on
Twitter no less so if there was any
executive privilege
Trump has pedaled it away the Trump
Russia octopus is now so large that his
apologists like Fox News have even gone
so far as to offer a kind of doomsday
defense collusion is not a crime only an
antitrust law said Greg Jarrett you can
collude all you want with a foreign
government in an election there's no
such statute
so Trump's not guilty of joining with an
enemy foreign government to fix the
presidential election or oh well maybe
he is but so what there ain't no law
against that
in fact if Trump colluded with the
Russians PolitiFact reported that he
could be guilty of fraud public
corruption conspiracy and receiving
illegal foreign campaign contributions
and if he traded something to the
Russians for their help like a vow to
lift sanctions against Russia or a vow
to destroy NATO well we have now moved
into the territory of espionage and
treason charges the original point here
the reporting on FBI and congressional
investigations of what happened when
Donald Trump and Sergei kiss lack met in
Washington on April 27th 2016 might be
the most important break yet in this
case or it might mean nothing because
not only does it get lost in the latest
giant bag of manure generated just this
week by this man occupying this
presidency but it also gets lost in the
amazing number of individual Trump
Russia scandals you may have seen this
on the Internet as best as I can find it
tracks back to early April and a repost
on a political cartoon website by
somebody calling themselves radish let
me read all of it except the fringy
stuff that doesn't hold much water
I don't know radish began it's hard for
me to see any US ties to Russia except
for the Flynn thing and the Manta Ford
thing and the Tillerson thing and the
sessions thing the Kushner thing the
Carter Page thing and the Roger stone
thing and the Felix seder thing and the
Boris Epstein thing an alleged Rosneft
thing and the supposed Gazprom thing and
the Sergey Gourcuff banker thing and the
Donald Trump jr. thing and the Sergey
kis lyac thing and the Russian
affiliated interest thing and the
Russian business interests thing and the
Alex Nader thing and hack of the DNC
thing and the Gucci 42.0 thing and the
Mike Pence I don't know anything thing
and Trump's public request to Russia to
hack Hillary's email thing and the Trump
house sale for a hundred million dollars
at the bottom of the housing bust to the
Russian fertiliser King thing and the
Russian fertilizer king's plane showing
up in Concord North Carolina during
Trump's rally campaign thing and the
newness sudden flight to the White House
in the night thing and the Cyprus Bank
thing and Trump not releasing his tax
returns thing and the Republican Party's
reject
of amendment to require Trump shows
taxes thing an election hacking thing
and the GOP platform change to the
Ukraine thing and the sealed dossier
thing and the Leninist Bannen thing and
the intelligence community's
investigative reports thing and Trump's
reassurance that the Russian connection
is all fake news thing and Spicer's
russian dressing there's nothing there
thing so there's probably nothing there
since the swamp has been drained these
people would never lie probably why
newness cancels the investigation of
meetings all of this must be normal just
a bunch of separate dots with no
connection and all that was before the
Trump kiss lack they resist peace